[Musique]
nous sommes à lima la capitale du pérou
face à une et noire historique une natte
détresse et même quelques cheveux courts
pour les hommes peuvent servir car un
kilo de cheveux peut absorber jusqu'à 8
litres d'hydrocarbures adieu le pass and
i ter place au pass vaccinale pour
l'obtenir toute personne âgée de 16 ans
et plus doit avoir un schéma vaccinal
complet si c'est votre cas aucune
démarche à faire votre pass sanitaire
sera automatiquement converties la marée
noire a été provoquée il ya neuf jours
par l'ondé de choc de l'éruption de
l'île tonga lorsqu'un bancaires a perdu
6000 barils de pétrole les organisateurs
de la primaire populaire ont annoncé
cette nuit quatre cent soixante sept
mille inscrits ils voteront donc du
jeudi 27 au dimanche 30 janvier pour
désigner parmi sept personnalités du
parti nous avons une opportunité d'avoir
une candidate ou un candidat qui a un
qui sort d'une investiture démocratique
citoyenne et qui répond à la demande
exprimée par toutes et tous à un moment
ou un autre exprimés par chaque
candidate et et chaque candidat de
rassemblement de la gauche beaucoup
d'entre eux sont désespérés aussi
d'entendre en permanence cette idée
selon laquelle des idées serait
illégitime des candidatures ne le serait
pas ils sont vides un peu de sérénité
quoi vous ne vous représentez pas aux
élections présidentielles je suis pas
candidat a pu remarquer
oui mais comme ça va pas bien c'est vrai
que
choisir presque une candidature de plus
serait utile je ne sais pas c'est une
voie de sortie et celles et ceux qui
veut pas le reconnaître a souvent
simplement pour ma part j'ai dit très
clairement que je reconnaissais les
règles et le résultat de cette primaire
est ce que vous allez prendre une
décision bientôt tu poses la question
prendre la parole bientôt je crois qu'il
a fait preuve de beaucoup d'humour de
seconde et je vais pas je suis pas là
pour commenter les petites phrases même
celle de françois hollande pense qu'il
ya une part de
plaisanterie mais il ya voilà il n'ya
pas que de la plaisanterie je sais pas
je ne sais pas non je ne sais pas
comment comment commenté ça je n'ai
absolument aucune envie de commenter ça
si j'étais né chez pécresse oui j'aurais
été un traître world gtl à la france est
soumise aurait été un traître mais là je
suis dans l' autorité du respect à mes
idées je dirais le mieux c'est pour mes
idées je rejoins eric si demain marion
se ranger du côté de d'eric zemmour ce
serait pour ce camp là et pour le
rassemblement national d'une autre en
plein si marion
rejoignez eric ça serait
ça serait quasiment plié bien évidemment
à la chirac ouais vous souvenez février
2002 dans son discours la maire
d'avignon marie-josée rouag demande au
président sortant s'il est candidat à sa
réélection est tout simplement la
surprise générale chirac lui réponds oui
en temps voulu je j'annoncerai ma
décision
j'ai déjà continuer à me battre jusqu'au
bout je peux vous le dire parce que
comme vous l'avez démontré vous même on
a encore beaucoup de choses à faire ce
serait pas un élu qui poseraient la
question mais un français un français
qui aborderait le chef de l'état dans la
rue au cours d'une déambulation et qu'il
lui poserait tout simplement cette
question là ce serait un peu scénarisé
alors enfin à ses torts et paraît
totalement scénarisé c'est tout avait
été réglé c'est pas le cas beaucoup de
temps mais il faut juste que je peux
dernier moment après je m'en serais ma
décision en temps voulu il a marqué la
mode et les années 80 90 avec ses
créations venues d'un autre monde où
voire d'un film de science fiction
thierry mugler avait également lancé
dans des parfums les plus populaires
angel et sa forme en étoile le créateur
français encore adoubé par les stars
américaines est mort hier il avait 73
ans